here we are summer still fat right still
fat yeah we're still fat it's alright
embrace it
embrace it this is us this is us we're
fat you're the really fat you think
you're fat you're trying not to be fat
either way
fats coming if you're not fat you're
working your ass off you don't eat food
and you're no fun to be with
embrace it you're winners that's why
you're fat you're winners
yeah part of the first generation that
doesn't have to fight for survival good
for you yeah that's right food
everywhere perfect temperature
everywhere you go every day you wake up
a perfect 72 in snackie Thank You
America it's good just embrace it don't
tell me what you're quitting don't tell
me what you're quitting I don't care I
don't care I'm quitting gluten I'm
quitting meat I don't care you're my
friend you looked awful yesterday
you're gonna look a little worse
tomorrow why are we talking about this
let's get some ice cream
my wife quit sugar in January because
she ate cookies like a monster all
through December and on January 1st
that's it I'm not eating sugar ever
again I'm never eating sugar again yes
you are and you're gonna eat more than
you ever ate before because you're gonna
snap in the middle of the month not
because you're a big fat pig but because
you're a human being and you get sad
sometimes and to stop yourself from
slitting your own throat heat a cookie
once in a while
you're fine
seriously this is it this is what you
are stop thinking you have to be
something else right every show has a
makeover segment on it right they take
some woman and they tell her she's not
good enough and therefore no women are
good enough right they always take a mom
just a mom just a worker just a mom and
a cheerio covered minivan with 15 kids
and 20 animals she didn't think her life
was gonna go this way she thought she
was gonna be a princess yeah that's what
they told her her whole life you're a
princess and on a wedding day they
dressed her up like a queen and she
thought she made it then she woke up the
next morning they took her veil away
they gave her some sweatpants and they
told her to get to work but she doesn't
care
she loves these people she works hard
for these people and what do they do in
return they pop out of a pantry with
Matt Lauer and screaming her face we're
giving you a makeover I thought I looked
all right no you're disgusting we had a
meeting when you were making us dinner
and we decided we're not gonna look at
this anymore then they dragged her ass
to the Today Show they put her in
clothes she can never afford or wear she
can't wear heels this big they're gonna
get stuck in the field when she's
putting up the soccer nets hair and
makeup she could never replicate with a
staff of five people in an extra three
hours before the bus comes and then the
worst part on national TV she comes
waddling out her heels trying not to
fall her whole family starts crying in
her face oh my god you're beautiful you
look nothing like you
you're doing fine I haven't met any of
you and I'm telling you you're doing
great this is as good as life is gonna
get I'll go one better you're peaking
right now
no really so embrace it you're doing
fine yeah you're not working out you're
not working out you're not gonna work
out
try but you're gonna skip and don't beat
yourself up when you do it's okay you
know why you're not working out because
you're smart people you're intelligent
you know your life isn't threatened so
there's no need to get running for like
crazy on some pretend getaway machine
you're fine
sure we're part of the fattest
generation okay
own it that's because your life is
awesome other generations yeah they were
skinnier but their lives were miserable
Gandhi didn't look like Gandhi cuz he
was killing it at SoulCycle
he wore a diaper and lived in the dirt
eating butterflies for lunch no so any
of these new exercises these
quote-unquote exercises I embrace all of
it my exercise now Apple watch yeah it
tells me to stand once an hour
time to stand Tom okay Apple watch how
am i doing a Fitbit get it get it people
you're winners get a Fitbit yeah strap
something to your arm count what you'd
normally do is exercise yeah get it
I walk from my car to my cubicle it's 80
steps yeah good job Carol you're an
athlete 5k next week you're a winner
thank you guys so much
[Applause]
you